(gentle piano music)
- I'm the first woman to
graduate with a Doctorate
from Julliard, and now
I play the toy piano.
Life works in mysterious ways.
(gentle piano music)
I have transformed the toy
piano into a real instrument.
To play the toy piano well,
you have to practice on it
every bit as hard as you
would on a normal piano.
In fact, I think you
have to work even harder,
because the action is so primitive.
You can make it sound beautiful.
You can make it sound convincing.
It's a bit like going down the rabbit hole
and taking your audience with you way back
down this avenue
to your childhood days.
(dramatic piano music)
(horns honking and squeaking)
(audience laughs)
Once a skeptical person
comes to a toy piano concert
that I give, I'm able to turn 'em around.
(applause)
It's a whole extended family
now of people into toy pianos.
It's a fearless little
band who are willing to
stick their necks out for toys.
(gentle piano music)
(delicate jingling)